foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to viewers around the world I'm
Piers Morgan and I'm uncensored
awesome Mandela might have said it's
been a long walk to freedom of speech
but now I'm back with a nightly forum
for fabulous gas Fearless debate and yes
some fun in fact just before we came on
air tonight I received a wonderfully
sincere good luck message from the
world's funniest man
the producers of Piers Morgan's new show
contacted me and asked me if I'd like to
be a guest I said definitely not
they said would you mind doing a quick
video wishing him luck I said do I have
to mean it they said no I said good luck
thanks Ricky as you may have heard other
rather Lively encounter with President
Donald Trump the most famous and
divisive man in the world present
company accept him it's already made
headlines across the entire globe and it
was the longest and most explosive
interview that I've ever done with him
okay peers I'm ready a former president
I'll be completely straight to your face
I think I'm a very honest man much more
honest than you actually really yeah it
was a free and fair election you lost
only a fool with things
excuse me okay with us
excuse me
explosive interview of the Year
let's finish up the interview versus
turn the camera
I'm definitely real Donald this is me
now president Trump's issued so far not
one but two furious statements about
that 30-second promo he says the
interview was long and tedious fake and
a shambles but he also says it was very
strong that he enjoyed doing it and he
predicts big ratings and the really good
news is apparently I'm not a complete
slime ball which is an enormous personal
relief
well more of a dramatic interview in a
few moments but first I want to issue an
urgent trigger warning
[Music]
for all Ultra sensitive permanently
offended woke snowflakes who may have
accidentally tuned in tonight you're not
going to enjoy this show in fact it's
going to really annoy you it may even
provoke trauma because I'm going to be
constantly celebrating the one thing you
can't buy free speech and that's real
free speech not your kind of free speech
what only your opinions are allowed and
anyone with a different opinion has to
be shamed abused and canceled their
careers and reputation is destroy no the
free speech is supposed to be the
Bedrock of any real Democratic Society
the kind words okay to disagree it's all
right to respect and tolerate each
other's views it's even okay to go for a
beer with someone you've just spent a
whole hour arguing with about the
burning issues of the day
many great people have said many great
things about free speech so Winston
Churchill said some people's idea of
free speech is that they are free to say
what they like but if anyone says
anything back that is an outrage
President George Washington said if
freedom of speech is taken away then
dumb and Silent we may be led like sheep
to the slaughter but my all-time
favorite came from The brilliantly
Fearless provocative and much misplanus
is Christopher Hitchens who said my own
opinions are not for me anyone who
disagrees with this can pick a number
get in line and kiss my ass
my sentiments exactly
nobody's getting canceled on Piers
Morgan uncensored this is a no cancel
Zone
[Music]
no opinion will be silenced no debate
will be off limits no BS will be
tolerated and yes if it's all right with
you we're going to enjoy ourselves I
couldn't put it better than my late
great friend the Australian cricket
genius Shane Warne one of the world's
most iconic sportsmen
and in this politically correct day and
age we've just got to be a little bit
careful but sometimes just say get stuff
to the fun police
well said Shane you heard the man fun
police get stuffed
my mission statement for this show is
very simple I'm going to cancel cancel
culture I'll defeat this Insidious
joyless societal Scourge with those most
effective of democracy preserving
weapons common sense and truth and
that's the truth by the way not your
truth and definitely not princess
Pinocchio's truth
I'll always fight your corner I'll
always have your back well unless you're
a liberal liberals who want to wreck
anyone with an opinion that you've ruled
as offensive or canceled Crusaders
rewriting history as one great sopping
apology conducting the
banishingquisition sailing the internet
on your Purity Purge stamping your
extremist views on the rest of the world
with no tolerance to any discussion or
debate or ideological imperialists
waving your digital snitchforks hounding
good men and women out of their jobs and
reputations because they tweeted
something you didn't like
or hypocrite celebrities multiplicating
about equality from their massive
mansions and constantly preaching one
thing while doing the complete opposite
themselves I think you know the type
write your Royal Highness
or trans Trojans engulfing the internet
in your flames of Rage when women dare
to say things like women exist
or Internet excavators raking over
ancient social media Profiles In Search
of fossilized evidence that someone you
disagree with wasn't Mother Teresa
or prevaricating politicians who lie
cheap break the law and blunder without
accepting accountability
all vegan virtue signals you want to
make mince meat out of people like me
for eating steak without seeing the
irony the one common trait of all these
people is insufferable
self-righteousness they don't just think
they're right they know their rights and
anyone who said otherwise must be
destroyed
well I've got some breaking news for you
tonight
nobody's right all the time not even me
although my record is mentally better
than most it's okay to be wrong it's a
right to evolve your opinions when facts
change whether you live in Britain
America Australia it's time we went back
to being real democracies silencing
censoring no platforming and canceling
people who disagree with you isn't
Democratic or liberal it's actually a
form of modern day fascism which of
course they profess to hate
I've always loudly and proudly stood up
for civil rights women's rights gay
rights and trans rights I always will I
Believe In fairness and equality for
everybody but that hasn't stopped the
white Brigade branding me racist sexist
homophobic and transphobic and that's
some of the nicer things they call me
all abusively spewed from people with
that disingenuous be kind hashtag in
their Twitter bias there's nothing kind
about these awful people not any room
for logical reason in that perverse
world of liberal authoritarianism
these are dangerous times for
democracies built on Free Speech we've
regressed thousands of years back to a
days when warring tribes of people who
look the same sounded the same dress the
same and thought the same marched around
Spears out bang for the blood of anyone
remotely different to themselves and
I've reached a very unfortunate
conclusion
I'm in a house right with statues of
Churchill Mandela
candy all have to be boarded up in
London's Parliament Square because woke
imbeciles might trash them for being
problematic
when tall powerful formerly male trans
athletes are smashing records in women's
sport
pregnant men get an emoji but women are
called birthing people
when Snow White's prince is a sexual
predator because for that kiss he didn't
ask for consent and when Mr Potato Head
has had his actual nuts removed
night after night I'll highlight this
nonsense for what it is nonsense because
the world has gone nuts and not even a
global pandemic or a war in Europe seems
to snapped us all out of it so that
Piers Morgan uncensored be your island
of Sanity your department of Common
Sense the last Refuge of the slant we're
Global we're going to annoy all the
right people and I'm uncensored
and if you're wondering why we could do
that
my show is called Piers Morgan
uncensored okay you like the title I
like it yeah very much I know you very
well you've loved me a lot for you it's
a good title I don't think you can avoid
it no so it's an accurate title I don't
think if they told you to behave
yourself you can't so it's probably a
very accurate title
and sends it next to World exclusive
interview with the most controversial
man possibly in the history of this
planet
okay peers I'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back now the most explosive
personality in political history in his
most explosive ever TV interview the
former leader of the Free World quite
possibly the next leader of the Free
World loved and loathed revered and
feared but never ignored and now
completely uncensored in the next hour
president Donald J Trump blows the roof
off the biggest issues in the world
today and he nearly blows my head off
too do you think I'm a thought I do now
yeah
nothing is off limits Trump reveals what
he told Putin about invading Ukraine I
threatened him like he has never been
threatened before his damning verdict on
President Biden if it's you against Joe
Biden if you win the Republican
nomination again and he runs again would
you beat him
uh I believe right now anybody I think
you could beat him right now
his thoughts on those Renegade Royals
I think poor Harry is being led around
by his nose and I think he's an
embarrassment
and the big question whether he'll run
again for president in 2024.
I think people are going to be happy you
might even be happy
he even gave his thoughts on me walking
off a certain TV show
I thought you overreacted by the way
well I'll tell you what happened I mean
the guy the guy was a stiff
we got wrong
I've known Donald Trump for 15 years
consider him to be a good friend albeit
one with as many flaws as qualities we
go back a long way to an iPad in this
Celebrity Apprentice TV show in 2008 and
I did well modestly speaking rather well
Pierce you're a vicious guy I've seen it
we can try and dispute it you can try
and dispute it you're tough you're smart
you're probably brilliant I'm not sure
you're certainly not diplomatic but you
did an amazing job and you beat the hell
out of everybody Pierce you're the
celebrity
[Applause]
I've interviewed him dozens of times
since then including on three occasions
since he won the presidency we generally
get on pretty well mutual respect even a
touch of affection but this time was
very different
minutes before our interview at Trump's
Estate and Home in Mar-A-Lago and Palm
Beach in Florida a truly dramatic moment
Trump was sent this dossier this is the
actual thing of the worst things I'd
said about him in the two years since
his dire handling of the coronavirus
pandemic and even more dire refusal to
accept losing the 2020 election which
sparked a deadly riot at the U.S capital
the dossier was sent to Trump by a
treacherous little weasel called Nigel
working for a little watch TV network
somewhere in the UK in an attempt to
sabotage this interview a sneaky plot
that was to spectacularly backfire these
are just some of those quotes and keep
in mind that he summons me to his office
and read them to me very slowly with
increasing Menace in his eyes
Trump for Supreme narcissist his
pathetic Antics have been utterly
contemptible
he's now acting like a mafia MOBA boss
president Trump needs to be removed from
office
now to be clear I meant what I said at
the time and I stand by it all now but
understandably Trump was angry Furious
in fact he cursed me as he read those
quotes out and repeatedly threatened to
cancel the interview it was a bit like
being back in the old Apprentice
boardroom moments away from possibly
being fired he shouted at me I thought
we were friends this is so disloyal why
would you sail this about me so I told
him I'm just being brutally honest
dishonest he snapped as he was to do
again later
it was tense it was touch and go but he
finally did agree to do the interview
then he didn't hold back but then
neither did I he'd agreed to 20 minutes
we ended up going toe-to-toe for more
than 70. and from the moment we sat down
I knew this would be the most explosive
Trump interview I'd ever done
president Trump well first of all how
are you very good we're doing well and
it's nice to be in Florida we're sort of
all over the place but a lot of times
spent in Florida what is life like as an
ex-president
well it's uh interesting it's beautiful
it's complex sometimes uh we have a lot
of endorsements going out and have gone
out we've done very well on endorsing
candidates that I think are very good
and they are very good and we've taken
people from who we're not going to win
and now they're winning big you're
talking like somebody who feels he has
unfinished business
well
we did a really good job we created an
economy that was incredible and now a
supply chain problems inflation problems
gasoline selling for five six seven
dollars think of it a gallon when I left
it was under two dollars and it was
largely under two dollars for a long
period of time 187
167 at one point and now it's five six
seven eight dollars depending on where
you are going up much higher uh and we
have a war that would have never
happened if I was president that war
would have never happened when the
invasion started you were quite
praiseworthy of Vladimir Putin you said
he was a genius this was a Savvy mood he
was going in as a peacemaker no no
that's the fake news's version no tell
me the truth when he built up soldiers
on the border I said that's very smart
brilliant move
because I thought he was negotiating
when he went in I said no longer a
brilliant move when you see the scenes
Mr President of maternity hospitals when
you see refugees being attacked as they
flee grandmothers children babies you
see the decimation of previously
prosperous cities living in a thriving
new democracy when you watch what's
happening I mean do you agree with my
assessment that Vladimir Putin is now an
evil genocidal monster yeah but I also
when I look at I do oh sure who wouldn't
what's happening is horrible when you
see Rockets going into apartment
buildings and there are plenty people in
those buildings you know they think
they're like the people who moved out
they didn't move they want to stay
because they think they're safe in their
Apartments far more people are dead than
you think when I see all the Death and
All That destruction and it's such a
stupid War because yet a country who was
working that was had problems lots of
problems but other other countries have
problems too it was such a horrible
waste to be doing it you see swings
outside you see playgrounds you see
hospitals it was a country
and the people were happy I guess a lot
of them were happy because they're
certainly fighting for it but I'll tell
you what I really think I said isn't it
a shame all those people are dead all
because of a rigged election because if
our election wasn't rigged you would
have had nobody dead when you said to
Putin don't invade Ukraine yeah what was
this well I told him what our response
was going to be and his response was
really I said really what did you say
your response and you know what if he
believed me good but if he believed me
only five percent he would have said
I'll never do it well did you say the
response I'm not going to say that I'm
not going to say that but it was a very
strong response did you threaten I said
for example the nuclear capability I
don't want to talk about this I don't
want to talk about that what I did say
is
we're going to be very strongly
responding if you do that I also said to
president XI don't go into Taiwan
and there's going to be a very strong
response they both understood that they
both had the same reaction really
really I said really the thing that may
keep him out of Taiwan is how poorly
Russia is doing right and how vicious it
has to be how horrible it has to be
because China sees that and nobody wants
to see what's happening so what would
you do right now in Ukraine if you were
the President Putin uses the n-word I
call it the n-word he uses the n-word
the nuclear word all the time that's a
No-No you're not supposed to do that he
uses it on a daily basis and everybody's
so afraid so afraid so afraid and as
they're afraid he uses it more and more
that's why he's doing the kind of things
he's doing he's doing them because he
thinks nobody's going to ever attack us
because they're all stupid and they're
afraid to talk I totally agree with you
okay so what'd you do instead of excuse
me it's a little complicated instead of
you know cow Towing instead of Biden
saying oh
he's got nuclear weapons he keeps saying
he's got no
we have better weapons that we have the
greatest submarine power in history what
would you say and do I would say we have
far more than you do far far more
powerful than you and you can't use that
word ever again you cannot use the
nuclear word ever again and if you do
we're going to have problems this is my
reading of what you've been saying is
that when you were talking to Putin when
you were president and he was talking
about potentially invading Ukraine that
you threatened him with your nuclear
capability I threatened him like he has
never been threatened before did you
threaten to use nuclear weapons I don't
want to say that I threatened him like
he has never been threatened before
what's your message for Putin now right
now if you could talk to him what would
you say to him I would say it's a shame
what you've done
you're killing protect I think
potentially look you know if if these
people aren't smart and they're not our
leaders are not smart
if they're not smart you can end up in a
nuclear war this is just the beginning
this is the beginning and I've been the
best predictor of things ever now it
doesn't have to happen it shouldn't
happen but if our people aren't smart
you can end up in a nuclear war what's
your message he's watching this
interview and he will be look what would
you say I think they're dealing with
them incorrectly I think what they're
saying
it's almost like they're speaking with
fear and they don't understand we have
one weapon alone that would destroy
everything should Putin get out of
Ukraine right now they should make a
deal and they can make a deal and they
should do it fast when people look back
on this period of time
we're going to be ashamed at what we've
done
or what we haven't done to stop this
catastrophe this is a catastrophe this
is in a way already a World War as
Russia made itself with this Invasion
has it made itself an enemy of the
United States well I think two things
have happened number one they've proven
to be less powerful than we thought
that's a good thing from our standpoint
but at the same time they have a second
degree of weapon that is very powerful
and
nobody can be allowed to use it talk
about it threaten with it we have more
powerful than them and there would be no
Russia there would be no Russia but we
don't want to talk about that but when I
watch Biden Joe he's got nuclear weapons
we can't do this you can't do that you
know I confronted Kim Jong-un
and all of a sudden I got a call they'd
like to meet
it was like and when you take your
funded him and we met what did you say
to him well verbally I confronted him
you know that
he said I have a red button on my desk
meaning a nuclear button I said I have a
red button on my desk too but it's
bigger and stronger than yours and mine
works and they said well nobody's ever
talked to us that way I took a lot of a
lot of heat when I said that would you
look back on your term in office and
there may be another one we'll come to
that when you look back on the the four
years you were president of the United
States it was very polarizing in many
ways you know that what do you think was
your biggest success
So when you say polarizing I think it's
more polarized now than it ever I don't
disagree I don't disagree Joe Biden said
he would unify the country yeah there's
certainly no sign of that happening so I
don't disagree with you well you know
that your own tent is to start with your
Technique we'll come to Joe Biden but
your tenure four years
give me the one thing that you're
proudest of I can't say one because
there are too many things but I'll give
you one that's a lot of people don't
talk about but then they say wow that's
true we started no Wars we didn't have
Russia fighting in Ukraine we didn't
have China threatening every day Taiwan
they wouldn't have done it and Russia
would have never go into they would have
never gone into Ukraine never no chance
how can you be sure about I know it I
know my people and I know Putin and he
would have never done it I think the the
Afghanistan withdrawal was so
incompetent
with the 85 billion and the dead
soldiers but to be clear you wanted
withdrawal you wanted US forces out of
Afghanistan I'm the one that started it
right I took it down no complaint is
about the execution of the withdrawal
that's the actual decision to withdraw
withdraw with strength and with dignity
but I was the one that got it down to
2000 so how would you have done it if
you'd still be in president number one
very simple I would have left the
military to last not you don't take out
the military first we took out our
military first
a child would say you can't do that we
took the military out and then we had
thousands of people that were American
people some of whom are still there a
large number are still there bigger than
people think uh I have never seen
anything so incompetent and in my
opinion by the way not only the soldiers
that were killed we have horribly
horribly wounded soldiers and leaving 85
billion dollars of the best equipment in
the world best military equipment I'm
leaving millions of Afghan women in the
hands of Taliban correct who have
immediately taken them back to the Dark
Age correct that's fine thrashing their
education trashing their women's rights
I mean that's an abrogation of a moral
duty isn't it yeah it sure is do you
think that it fueled Vladimir Putin's
Ambitions with the Ukraine Invasion
seeing what appeared to be America in
surrender mode yes I think that was the
reason I think that's why he did it when
they saw the way we acted in Afghanistan
the way we ran like surrendered and
again you have to understand I had a
very strong very powerful relationship
powerful in the sense that they
respected our country and me there was
no games with the Taliban and its leader
who's still their Leader by the way and
they would have never done this I agree
we ran away he said hey this is no
longer Trump I'm going to go in and take
you but let me let me and then it worked
out to be not so good
on since the next Trump and I fall out
over who's more honest
yeah I think I'm a very honest man much
more honest than you actually really
yeah I'm pretty honest because I don't
think you're real
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
Donald Trump's damning verdict on
British prime minister Boris Johnson he
tells me where he thinks Johnson's now
getting it all wrong and I ask him why
Boris intervened to get my last
interview with Trump canceled two hours
before it was due to start
Trump also has some scathing words for
the former German Chancellor Angela
Merkel and tells me why he sent her a
white napkin of surrender the first the
question that seemingly everybody in the
world is desperate to know the answer to
will Donald Trump run for president
again in 2024
so here's a big question for you which
everybody wants to know the latest poll
says if the 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat Joe Biden by six
points and Kamala Harris by 11 points in
other words you would be re-elected
president of the United States so are
you going to run again well you know for
reasons of campaign finance and
everything I'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this I think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
I I love our country our country is
going to hell I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy you're going
to run I'm not going to say that but I
think people are going to be happy you
might even be happy if it's you against
Joe Biden if you win the Republican
nomination again and he runs again would
you beat him
I believe right now anybody I think you
could beat him right now our country's a
mess our country has never been so
disrespected our borders have never been
so open we've never had in 44 years
inflation like we have it he's running
again and you win
which could well happen I think whoever
the Republican candidate right now it
looks like the Democrats are going to
get shellacked in the midterms it's
quite likely whoever is a republican
nominee will end up being president it
could be you again
and for as many people who think that's
a great idea you'll know there are lots
of people who think that would be a
total nightmare far less far less I
think so yeah I think for for us I think
people are very angry at this country
they're very angry at our leadership uh
they wish they had their vote to do
again we didn't need their vote because
again we won the election by a
tremendous margin we won the election
actually very easily
one of the other questions about
potentially running again is you've been
in that pressure cauldron of the White
House with your family they've all come
under huge attack their children your
wife Melania
would you be happy to put them back in
there would they be happy to be back in
there well I won't get into that but I
will tell you they all love the country
and we did a great job and it's been a
tumultuous time for the world for the
country
there is a chance that you're going to
be running quite clearly you've made
that clear in this interview I don't
think I've made it clearly I think
that's it but I think people are going
to be very happy I don't know there'll
be people unhappy but I think people are
going to be very happy so those who are
who don't like you
there's people out there that don't like
you I know you said recently that you
were very popular and I think you seem
to be the most honest man in the world
I'm a very honest man was that true yeah
I think I'm a very honest man but for
those who don't like you much more
honest than you actually really yeah I'm
pretty honest because I don't think
you're real yeah I think I'm a much more
honest person in most ways and most
recently why am I not real but we're not
going to get into that let's finish up
the interview go ahead
ahead go ahead my question was this what
message do you have to people who
can't think of anything worse than you
running again and will be distressed
about it would you come back with all
the experience you've had of being
president would you come back a
different person would you do things a
bit differently so I like this question
in a certain way because I came in and I
was attacked from day one
unfairly Russia Russia Russia was a hoax
the impeachment hoax number one number
two it was all a big hoax the Mueller
report
and I had a fight back and I had to
fight back strongly and if I didn't
fight back strongly I wouldn't have
survived and I say it and I say it loud
I had two jobs to do
run the country really well and the
second was to survive no other president
went through this fake stuff I only ask
these women did Celebrity Apprentice
together
which I really enjoyed it was good yeah
yeah yeah the one I did that with you I
saw a very different Donald Trump in the
boardrooms for those hours every night
you were you know you weren't as
aggressive and confrontational except I
wasn't Under Siege with phony with phony
Russia Russia hunts and by the way the
Russian collusion thing was ridiculous
no no and many others right but my point
is if you've got a chance again
would we see more of that Donald Trump
do you think depends on how you're
greeted but if you're greeted unfairly
you have to be tough and you have to
fight I would like that I would much
prefer that but it depends on how you
greet it but I would do when I say this
our country's in trouble
something has to happen and if it
doesn't happen and if we don't have
Smart leadership you're going to end up
with no world the world is going to be
blown to Pieces we have stupid people
now running our country the world is
going to be blown to pieces
what's a cheery thought isn't it uh and
a ferocious verdict on the United States
under President Joe Biden in his first
term in the Oval Office but what about
Britain under the leadership of Boris
Johnson and why did Johnston cancel my
interview with Trump a few days before
his 2019 UK election
there's some interesting answers but
first Trump's utterly withering verdict
on former German Chancellor Angela
Merkel they never got on well and
perhaps you can now understand why
you were very critical of Angela Merkel
in Germany for being so energy dependent
on Russia you've been completely
Vindicated
in fact her reputation is getting
shattered with every day of this
conflict it should be shattered she
should have never done it I had it out
with her I sent her the white flag of
surrender I sent her a white flag it was
in the form of a large Central one oh
yeah I had it brought right over to it a
different table I said it's the white
flag of surrender she said but what do
you mean I said you are dependent on
Russia for energy
you you must be kidding I mean just look
at the history of Germany and Russia
when it happens you might as well just
do me a favor lift this flag of
surrender you know what it was it was a
very luxurious
napkin okay where was it and I sent it
what did you do at one of the meetings
at one of our many meetings we had with
uh you know between the G7 the G20 you
have all the different G's and but I
said I said
you're going to be someday in a problem
with Russia and you are going to have no
choice but to surrender because the new
German leaders done a complete U-turn he
recognizes what you were saying then was
that completely correct but who wouldn't
recognize I also think that when she
took in millions of people she hurt
Germany very badly millions of people
flowed through Europe and flowed into a
country she heard on set of resettling
them someplace and spending money but
settling in their area where they would
rather be anyway the war forced them out
Bush got us into that mess in the Middle
East bush has done a tremendous
disservice people forget we were
supposed to meet in December 2019 just
before the pandemic in London and at the
last minute you canceled my interview
because of an intervention from the
British prime minister I believe
well that's true I mean you knew that
and I was over there as his guest so if
he asks me not to do that I have to do
that we have had why didn't he want you
to talk to me I don't know I didn't even
ask him the election the UK election was
a few days later yeah I was told it was
because he was worried that between us
we might create something that made cost
him the election well I like them and
I've always liked him I think he's
getting a little bit liberal he's
getting a little bit green
and since the next box pliers things
begin to get a lot more heated between
myself and the former president he has a
pretty forthright view on me
and I guess you're a fool only a fool
would think that was a legitimate I do
now yeah
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
but he categorically did not win the
2020 election he lost Joe Biden won and
Trump's been a really really sore loser
ever since I also believe his refusal to
admit defeat inspired and perhaps
incited a violent mob to descend on the
U.S capital on January 6 2021 some of
the most shocking scenes American
democracy has ever witnessed I was
appalled by these scenes and I've always
felt the Trump should have taken more
responsibility for what was
unequivocally an attempt to prevent the
peaceful Handover of power after a
democratic election here's what I said
at the time
he didn't just cross the line he
trampled all over that line and he's now
a threat to American democracy and to
those who warned this was what was going
to happen with Trump you've been proven
right
I stand by that and I put it directly to
the former president
the things I'm not happy about with your
presence I'll be completely straight
with you to your face one of them is
what happened on January 6th which was a
result of you refusing to accept the
result of the election before you slow
this okay Nancy Pelosi is in charge of
security she didn't do her job she's
half in charge of it so the Republican
the mayor of excuse me
the mayor of D.C and Nancy Pelosi are in
charge actually Republicans and the
Democrats have 50 50. but she was
actually cowering for Terror in fear of
her life that day because there was a
huge mob of people if she were attacking
the the center of Democracy in America I
want to read you what Mitch McConnell
said who's the Senate minority well
Mitch McConnell is not a good
representation you can respond to what
he says but he still remains he remains
he remains the senior Republican
unfortunately okay but he is right now
we'll see what happens okay fair enough
but he said this he's acknowledged that
Joe Biden was legitimate winner of the
2020 election he's rejected your claims
of Fraud and he said about January the
6th we're all there we saw what happened
it was a violent Insurrection for the
purpose of trying to prevent the
peaceful transfer of power after a
legitimately certified election from one
Administration to the next that's what
it was he told Mr the Senate on February
the 13th last year former president
Trump's actions preceding the riots were
a disgraceful dereliction of Duty
he then said there's no question that
President Trump is practically and
morally responsible for provoking the
events of that day and even this he said
about the rioters they did this because
they've been fed Wild falsehoods by the
most powerful man on Earth because he
was angry he'd lost an election number
one
he knew nothing about what took place in
the election the Press hates to write
about it but that election was rigged
and it was stolen you said to me 100 I
don't mean a little bit and you know
it's funny when a Hillary Clinton or
when uh Stacey Abrams says oh the
election was rigged nobody says anything
but when Trump says it but the
difference is I have proof and we have
massive proof okay but let me ask all
you have to do is take a look let me ask
you take a look at the ballot harvesting
that took place let me ask you this
Millions you said to me once that if you
talk the talk and you're a great talker
I've seen that today if you taught the
talk you have to walk the walk in the
context of your claim about the forged
election it's been 14 months and we've
not seen this hard evidence of the fraud
that you say happened the Press won't
report it the Press you haven't this is
like a communist country it's all over
the place we have not sorry about
everything let's just put another thing
to you because I've watched this whole
debate rays and you've been completely
really unflagging in your refusal to
accept defeat you know why though you
know why because if our country doesn't
have fair and free elections and if our
country doesn't have borders we don't
have a country okay we have crooked
corrupt elections here's what I would
say and I've proven it it's what I'm
saying to you I believe it was a free
and fair election and that you lost you
don't really believe it that's my belief
well then you're a fool however then
you're a fool maybe I am a fool maybe
I'm the fool in in this conversation and
you're a fool and you haven't studied
okay I have studied it
well maybe I am a fool but of course
I've studied it I've read a lot about
what happened with the 2020 election and
I see no hard evidence like I told him
that there was substantial voter fraud
nobody has seen that but the bottom line
with all this is Trump seems to me to be
fighting on the wrong Hill about why he
was treated unfairly in 2020. there's
another argument that he could produce
which I think is a lot more Merit just
three weeks before the election the New
York Post published a sensational front
page story about Hunter Biden son of the
now President Joe Biden emails found on
Hunter's abandoned laptop contained
proof that he sold influence while his
father was vice president
but the liberal runs social media Giants
squashed the scandal with Twitter and
Facebook shamefully blocking the post
scoop they even stopped the post having
an account
a mainstream media dismissed it all as
Russian disinformation so none of them
reported it properly and some believe
that if they had done it could have
swung the election in Trump's favor in
other words if more people had known
about this story if more people had
scrutinized this story if it hadn't been
so wrongly censored that they might have
vote to differently or stayed at home I
put this to president Trump
there is another twist in this tale
where I think you're on much stronger
ground and where I would agree with you
and that is the suppression of the
hunter Biden laptop Scandal which is
what it's become and it could lead right
to the top with Joe Biden we don't know
yet but it seems to me that the way that
mainstream media and the tech Giants
conspired to suppress that story
literally removing it from social media
platform 17. not reporting it not
chasing it 50 senior people coming out
saying this was Russian disinformation
all complete nonsense there is a belief
that that could have swung the election
your way in other words when you talk
about having a stolen election actually
you're on better ground it seems to me
with the hunter Bible are you ready I'm
sorry they say it made a 17-point
difference but you know what even
without that I want it and we want it
big and we want it easily it was so
corrupt and it was so corrupt in
Wisconsin that they're saying what do we
do they don't know what to do they
caught them so
only a fool and I guess you're a fool
only a fool would think that was a
legitimate you think I'm a vote I do now
yeah Frank Sinatra said the best revenge
is massive success
isn't your best revenge rather than
talking constantly about the last I
don't talk constantly but you brought it
up you brought it up excuse me you
brought it up I didn't I don't talk
about it very much I do say it was
rigged Mitch McConnell
is stupid and he shouldn't have allowed
it to happen but he did but if you look
at the results and if you look at what
happened but even you sitting here
saying well that doesn't matter but the
law I think the law is look I think the
law is even the numbers your own vice
president Mike Pence says you lost the
election Mike was the head of the
Republicans because you lost it Mike was
foolish and he was weak
thank you
it's an incredible thing to say about
Mike Pence someone who was probably the
most loyal vice president and most
supportive vice president in modern
American political history but no
because he doesn't think that election
was rigged or stolen he too gets thrown
under the bus
well that was the end of part one of my
extraordinary interview with Donald
Trump on tomorrow's Piers Morgan
uncensored will show part two which
contains a number of further remarkable
Revelations now the president and I
didn't agree about everything as you
just seen but there were some things we
did agree about including the Duke and
Duchess of Netflix and Mr Trump didn't
pull his punches when it came to the
Dynamics of of Harry and Megan's
relationship
Harry is whipped do you know the
expression I'm familiar I won't use the
full express but Harry is whipped like
no person I've ever seen the most weak
man in the world I don't know that's
going to be a big one but he is he is a
whipped man yeah
his predictions didn't stop there he
suggested the Royal fairy tale could be
rather short-lived so I want to know
what's going to happen when Harry
decides he's had enough of being bossed
around or maybe when she decides that
she likes some other guy better I want
to know what's going to happen when it
ends okay you think he's gonna win I do
I've been a very good predictor as you
know I predicted almost everything it'll
end and it'll end bad and I wonder if
Harry's going to go back on his hands
and knees back into
uh the beautiful city of London and say
please you know I think Harry has been
LED down a path
so not a fan of the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex but Donald Trump is a great fan
of other members of the royal family
including her majesty the Queen and
Camilla the queen in waiting she was on
my right the queen was on my left and I
said Queen I really have to talk to
Camilla for a little while too you know
we no we we couldn't break apart and I
talked to Camilla and Camilla was so
nice
you know different than I thought she
was funny she was smart quick
there was one other quite simple
question I wanted to put to Donald Trump
it's one that's troubled many
politicians at the moment and it's this
what is a woman this was his reply a
woman is somebody that swims at a
certain time and doesn't get beaten by
38 seconds by somebody that wasn't even
a good swimmer as a male
and as Elon Musk has made his bed to
take over Twitter this is Donald Trump's
response to what he perceives to be the
hypocrisy of the social media platform
because they did which I think are
really contentious one they've continued
to ban you from from the platform but
they allow Vladimir Putin to have a
Twitter account they allow the supreme
leader of Iran to have a Twitter account
they allow a number of Taliban leaders
to have a Twitter account I don't see
how they can square off allowing those
people to have their platform you know
what I'm not a former president of the
United States do you know why because
they're sick they're mentally ill
well Trump even gives his forthright
take on my walkout from Good Morning
Britain
I chose the title because I lost my last
job the Good Morning Britain show I
thought you overreacted by the way well
I'll tell you what happened and the guy
the guy was a stiff and I wasn't about
him it wasn't actually about the walkout
so you made it about him he got he got
probably got another yeah you're right
about it
he's not wrong uh there's been an
enormous amount of speculation a lot
more of course about the way the
interview ended much of it fueled by
President Trump himself our free
basically called it a rigged promo did
he storm out or didn't he it's a bit
more complicated than that one thing's
for sure it was a pretty acrimonious
final few minutes and he did
indisputably leave the room in a
stinking temper
uh I think it's fine it's fine
fantastic in Europe let's finish up the
interview turn the camera off
um that's not that cheerful does it does
it well tomorrow night I'll show you
that ending in full and also this week
another explosive interview with my good
friend the TV Superstar Sharon Osborne
in a remarkably revealing and
heart-rending account of what happened
to her when she got canceled for
defending me over the Meghan Markle
debacle Cheryl lost her job she was
subjected to disgusting vitriol even
horrific death threats all for saying
that I was entitled to have an opinion
but now she's back and I'm gonna
uncancel her on this show so that she
can now go back where she belongs and be
the queen of TV
Pierce and I had both been through
similar experiences
peers spoke about Megan and I spoke
about the way I feel for peers to have
his freedom of speech
after all the big huha all the mess
online
I am back to talk to Piers Morgan about
what really happened
what people can expect from the
interview is the truth
you don't think Council culture exists
watch that interview coming later in the
week well that's it the first ever Piers
Morgan uncensored thank you for being a
part of television history and remember
sometimes just say get stuff for the fun
police and whatever you're up to make
sure it's uncensored
thank you